What has been the consequence
of consequence was wild
sexual experimentation.
And why not?
What would you expect?
It's like all of a sudden
reproductions under control.
But does that mean that women
can be as promiscuous as men?
Well,
maybe that's what it means.
We don't know.
So that was part of the big sixties
experiment and it isn't obviously obvious
the debt went particularly well.
Um,
it's certainly led to the
pornography location of our society,
which I think is,
I really think is actually quite dreadful.
Um,
maybe that's my innate prudishness,
but I don't know,
it seems to me that pornography demeans
the participants as well as the viewers.
There's something second
rate and furtive about it.
And I think that everybody
who engages in it knows that,
um,
it's,
uh,
it's an,
it's a substitute for the
real adventure of life.
And I do think that it
leads to a certain kind of,
uh,
perhaps contempt.
It leads to contempt.
Um,
and,
and that can't be a good thing.
I mean,
I don't ever think,
and you guys can ask
yourself this question.
I mean,
have you ever met anybody who can finished
masturbating and then was proud about
it and who stood up
straighter because of it?
The new felt that they've really
conquered life as a consequence?
I mean,
I just don't believe that that's the,
that that's the,
the general post masturbation feeling.
I don't believe,
I believe that it's,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
it's,
it's something you do when you,
when you don't have the
right thing to do and,
and it's an admission that you're
a second rate player essentially.
Something like that.
So the pornography
vacation was a bad thing.